good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight quote what is our goal
get him to lie so we can prosecute or
get him fired end quote
those are from handwritten notes of a
senior FBI official plotting with others
to frame and potentially prosecute
General Michael Flynn which happened we
told you earlier this week that it did
happen and that a smoking gun was coming
to prove it happened that smoking gun is
here tonight we've got breaking details
for you on it in just a moment but first
we want to begin with an update on the
state of this country on Saturday former
President Barack Obama went golfing at
the Robert Trent Jones Country Club in
suburban Virginia he's a member there
Obama was driven to the course about 40
miles from his home in the District of
Columbia by a government show for here's
a picture of it from Politico if you
look you can see that Obama is clearly
enjoying himself and honestly why
wouldn't he be it's beautiful out on the
links and airy you'll notice there
aren't many people around and that's
because both Virginia and Washington DC
are still under quarantine everybody
else is locked at home as they have been
for more than a month but not former
President Obama for him golfing at his
Country Club was an essential activity
now two days later after this picture
was taken the beleaguered residents of
Washington DC began to receive a public
service announcement on their phones the
message had been recorded at the request
of the DC government by Barack Obama's
wife the former first lady Michelle
Obama here's what the message said
remember we urge you to stay home except
if you need essential health care
essential food or supplies or to go to
your central job stay home except for
essential health care essential food
essential jobs that is Michelle Obama's
message to you it didn't seem to occur
to her that those standards might also
apply to her family and that's why she
didn't mention essential trips to your
Country Club the fact that the rules
apply to them doesn't seem to occur to
anyone in power at the moment
just a few weeks ago Lori Lightfoot the
mayor of Chicago was caught getting her
hair done at a time when the city of
Chicago had closed salons to mere
civilians like foot stylists ratted her
out on face book her excuse quote I'm
the public face of this city I'm on
national media and I'm out in the public
eye
in other words said Lightfoot I'm far
more important than you are shut up
across the country our leaders are
making a mockery of the quarantines they
so enthusiastically enforce they have no
intention of abiding by the restrictions
they impose on their fellow citizens
they've no interest in any scientific
development and increasingly there are
many of them that challenges the wisdom
of their lockdowns day by day evidence
accumulates that mass quarantines are
not achieving what politicians claim
they would achieve not even close
huge numbers of people have been
infected anyway far fewer of them are
dying than we expected our political
leaders meanwhile pretend as if none of
this is happening just yesterday Maine
Governor Janet Mills extended her
state's lockdown into the indefinite
future she commanded citizens to remain
in their homes except for essential
activities and quote occasional grocery
shopping
Mills prohibited bars and restaurants
and summer camps and some state parks
from opening she made it illegal for
hotels to book guests even for future
stays she canceled every summer festival
in the state she told every Church to
keep its doors locked
ensuring that many of them will go
defunct and disappear forever and she
told the people of Maine to change their
personal lives including in the most
intimate ways no shaking hands the
governor ordered with great emphasis
thanks to Janet Mills decisions Maine
will never be the same but these
restrictions are all necessary she
explained thanks to the extreme and
unusual peril that the state of Maine
faces I want to be clear we are not out
of the woods yet and likely will not be
for some time not out of the woods yet
those are bracing words they sound like
something that Winston Churchill might
have said during the Blitz so what
exactly do these woods Janet Mills refer
to look like what the very moment she
a grand total of 33 people were being
treated in Maine hospitals for the
coronavirus 33 people out of a
population of more than 1.3 million
people over the full course of this
entire epidemic just 51 people in the
state of Maine have died from the corona
virus meanwhile and there's always a
flipside directly because of the
lockdowns that Mills ordered more than
10 percent of Maine's population is now
unemployed all over the state businesses
are failing a forecast produced by
Oxford economics predicts that Maine
will be hit harder and longer by these
lockdowns than any other state in the
country so is this a proportionate
response to the threat no it's not it's
vandalism Mills his speechwriter worked
hard to make her reckless policy sound
poetic people who now are staying apart
so that someday we can all be together
again someday we can be together again
well thanks governor we appreciate your
kindness and allowing them so how long
will that be
until we can be together again well
Mills who is clearly deeply enjoying her
newfound power didn't specify how long
there's quote no timeline for that
things will not be normal soon she
warned we were inventing a new normal
and quote now you may be wondering where
exactly does Janet Mills derive the
power to invent a quote new normal for
1.3 million people to remake human
society in whatever form she chooses
Mills did not explain that either
instead the governor read a selection
from a 31 year old novelist called
Veronica Roth Roth wrote that quote
gritting your teeth through pain is part
of the quote slow walk toward a better
life deep thoughts from Janet Mills a
slow walk toward a better life
that's what Mills is promising but wait
a second was this all supposed to be
about a public health emergency the
latest epidemiology science yeah that
was last month it's now about quote a
better life people in power abuse their
power that may be the lesson here the
arrival of a terrifying new virus from
China gave
leaders more power than anyone has had
in the history of this country
six weeks ago America was something
resembling an imperfect democracy we had
an election on the horizon that we are
sort of paying attention to back then
Andrew Cuomo was considered a thuggish
possibly corrupt regional leader but
suddenly everything has changed now this
is an oligarchy managed by bureaucrats
and tech moguls none of whom are
accountable to voters our leaders are
making decisions that will affect your
family forever with virtually no
oversight or accountability and of
course they love it we shouldn't be
surprised they don't want it to end
Jeff Bezos for example has made billions
of dollars since the lockdown began how
shocked are you that his personal
newspaper The Washington Post is arguing
that the highest possible volume that
the lockdowns must continue not very
shocked they all feel that way this is
the best thing that has ever happened to
them it's their chance let's say you
once tried to run the country but on two
separate occasions voters rejected you
they disliked you and they disliked your
program so much that they elected a
casino owner from reality television
instead what if that happen to you
you'd probably be pretty stung by it and
bitter and then one day you wake up and
the country is in chaos normal life has
been suspended this is the perfect
opportunity to impose your will on a
paralyzed nation you would seize that
opportunity and she has every form of
health care should continue to be
available including reproductive health
care then eventually and quickly I hope
gets us to universal health care this
would be a terrible crisis to waste as
the old saying goes more abortion
universal health care those are the
required responses to the Wu hen
coronavirus declares Hillary Clinton
yeah every politician on all sides has
an ideological wish list usually its
fullest ranged unlikely ideas that under
normal circumstances are kept in check
by voters as a group
voters instinctively distrust ideology
and for good reason
no one's keeping those ideas in check
now nobody cares what voters think
anymore it's time to govern
without limits watch disgraced New York
Mayor Bill DeBlasio explained that as a
matter of public health or something we
need more quote inclusion and equity
this city was written off more times
than I can count this city came back
stronger every time now we're gonna come
back stronger and fairer immediate
actions the city government needs to
take and build out as part of the bigger
vision is a City Task Force on racial
inclusion and equity focusing on the
disparities we're seeing already making
sure that we are addressing structural
racism that is obviously present in the
realities we're facing with this disease
so this pandemic is really about
structural racism that's what Bill de
Blasio was telling us bet you didn't
know that but you assumed it was a virus
remember how confused are you doesn't
matter because Bill de Blasio doesn't
care what you think like all of our
leaders from now on he plans to do
exactly what he wants and he can